bonjour
comment allez vous
jma tiounov dérangés en plein déjeuner
parce que ça s'est bien passé le
passeport vacciner maintenant tester mon
passeport j'ai pas l'application jamais
me d'applications sur mon téléphone j'ai
aucune idée comment ça marche maintenant
mais je les trouvais en pdf puis qui
tout va très bien
donc c'était l'exigence là pour vous
allez pas exagéré de menville pas non
mais si ça voulait rester en forme
à quelques pas on fait nos joueurs je
pense pour les commerçants c'est le fond
qui puisse rester ouvert il y en a mangé
toute une semaine dernière on va leur
donner un bris alors le patro vaccinale
sent pas été du chul ce matin super ça
super bien été ça va faire partie de
notre quotidien maintenant puisque si ça
peut aider à sauver des vies
à désengorger des hôpitaux je vois pas
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait sauver quoi que
on pourrait pas l'avoir donc pour vous
ce n'est pas une entrave à la liberté
parce que des gens peuvent actionner qui
ne pourront plus rentrer ici non c'est
aucune maman très vallée de berthet au
contraire c'est pour une liberté à
soi-même et à tout le monde bonjour
monsieur ça va bien une excuse à ou
dérangés en plein repas le passeport
vaccinale ce que vous l'avez présenter
ça a été compliqué oui ce jeu les
présentes et sauf a été compliqué
et ça a pris combien de temps quand vous
êtes entré deux secondes je dirais moins
d'une minute oui bon moins d'une minute
de présenter à la question
1 m'a dit oui ce qu'on veut
bon appétit
êtes vous vacciner avez vous
savez utiliser au café en ce moment dont
vous allez la présenter pour vous c'est
bien de demander ça les gens soient
vaccinés ce qu'ont fait les obliger les
avez vous des amis qui sont pas vaccinés
ne veulent rien savoir non pas vraiment
en étant les étudiants à l'université je
pense qu'on a tout compris que c'est
vraiment important là on est content de
revenir présentiel pied en tout cas pour
moi le fait d'avoir le passeport si
encourageants pour continuer à l'emprise
anciens puis recommencer à vivre donc je
pense pour ceux qui avouent que nos amis
qui vont tout à l'université on sait
très importants soient vaccinés parce
que ça a été dur étudie changera tout
seul ainsi la première fois quand on est
en présence le pied c'est on remarque
immédiatement la différence lac est
moins important ah oui bon je sais pas
comment je vais loin des collègues loin
des profs
j'étudiais à quoi on est au bac en
administration à hec même si elles sont
il a même cru bon bravo bonne journée
bonjour tout le monde je fais un
reportage patrie soit radio canada sur
le passeport vaccinale madame ont levé
la main je veux
c'est comme à l'école
bonjour mais désolé de vous déranger
manger à sa l'herbe on a plus alors ce
n'est pas un bon exemple parce que nous
sommes français dans ce cas de bari et
on trouve un petit peu curieux nous chez
nous nous allons deux passeports déjà un
français et un européen et chez vous
c'est ni l'un ni l'autre il va falloir
un troisième passeport mais est ce
qu'ils ont accepté votre passeport
français
oui mais le court chrono pas valable
l'émirat ne peut passer les trains venus
avec votre mec est un système de lecture
c'est quand même une preuve de vagues
d'eau bien sûr c'est pas compliqué mais
n'est-ce pas compliqué du tout non pas
compliqué du tout on a notre téléphone
on peut avoir un papier si on veut non
c'est pas compliqué est ce qu'il ya eu
des récalcitrants au projet pôle
équestre am aujourd'hui depuis à me dit
souvent de pure 11h30 le paul ricard
puis vous il ya beaucoup de monde
d'accord la terrasse est actuellement à
plein tout le monde tout le monde le des
foyers ont pas exactement le maxi conne
mais ils ont le photo donc testons mij
pas encore elle reste toujours à xi code
ça va être le vôtre appuyez dessus votre
nom vous l'avez six mois d'application
ici à côté je vais jouer comme ça
voilà battre et se voit certifié par le
gouvernement du québec donc c'est un
prix exactement à 28,5 en même pas même
moi je dirais oui
voila merci beaucoup à briser tout de
suite
non